hello and welcome to co playing off from
Denmark the other action is probably a
little bit slower currently on the SSC
simply because the chess olympiad there
are that many picture plane that are
often regulars on the ASUC so here's a
funny side line that is not easy for
black to handle 97 it's already slightly
questionable takes Queen takes is very
annoying and I'm taking this yeah how
does like getting this back 9 a-6 maybe
but I have stuff like win a 3-night e6
okay so Queen a3 I guess just protect it
Quincy 7s 95 so
Queenie forecheck is a very tricky
variation luck has to know his stuff
down if he doesn't he gets a position
like that very tough for black here to
maintain a play of the position yeah but
still if I go night g5 I have to go whoa
really I can I g5 or something why isn't
that disastrous threatened 97 winning
the Queen
now that side of it in I don't see move
here from Black here I can take probably
six and then 9790 Bishop b2 is that
something and I can I can actually do
not see seven done or not let's think
about it something easier I don't think
so it this is easy enough I guess that's
his cell it's a pretty serious fork two
rooks and especially so I think this is
the one to take the night will be
rescued um I think quite easily with c6
if i'm not mistaken mmm c6
yeah but you came it's not much that
black can do anyway um just take this
here
t8 coming I Bishop f4 also was quite
good
black resigns yeah that it was an
opening opening problem them and that
line create for is quite interesting
okay the the problem flag is a little
bit if you don't know what to do you can
get into trouble very easily the best
move was Bishop to d7 and I mean that's
not totally obvious said this is the
best move this is already leading into
some problems because i'm opening up
with deform and blacks nights are not
well positioned here in ideally i given
castle crack castle haruki one at ND for
and it is a catalan and the nights are
just not good g6 or ecigs now g64 jab is
the problem if you take this is also
very nice for wide right here they are
you of your pond down I mean the
position he has more or less more or
less losing his strong budgets you will
definitely lose against an engine it's
on 1.3 it's a pawn and black as some
boxed in and gentleman justice which the
house already the Queen Esther in this
discovery okay and this is this is just
a rock a full-fledged opening disaster
not that much to add ok guys thanks for
watching